bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la décohérence quantique à
l'échelle des atomes les objets et
notamment les particules sont décrits
par la physique quantique en physique
quantique une particule peut se trouver
dans des superpositions d'état par
exemple une superposition de plusieurs
positions en même temps cependant si on
plonge cette particule superposés dans
un environnement qui n'est pas vide avec
par exemple d'autres particules de la
lumière ou encore de la chaleur alors
notre particules va se mettre à
interagir avec tous ces éléments qui
l'entourent en interagissant de la sorte
avec son environnement
la particule valeur subir un phénomènes
quantiques qui va peu à peu estompé ces
superpositions
c'est ce que l'on appelle la décohérence
au cours du temps le phénomène de
décohérence va progressivement rendre
indétectables la superposition quantique
de la particule ainsi après un certain
temps
bien que la particule se trouve toujours
dans un état superposé
le fait d'avoir interagit avec son
environnement a rendu cette
superposition complètement indétectable
la particule alors perdu ses propriétés
quantiques d'origine
le phénomène de décohérence permet ainsi
d'expliquer pourquoi à notre échelle on
ne trouve pas d'objets du quotidien
présentant des propriétés quantiques
en effet un objets macroscopiques comme
par exemple une pomme est formé d'une
très grande quantité de particules
toutes ces particules qui le composent
vous donc interagir entre elles est
ainsi très rapidement par le phénomène
de décohérence l'objet va perdre toute
propriété quantique
plus la particule va interagir avec
beaucoup d'éléments plus la décohérence
va être rapide
[Musique]
ainsi dans notre quotidien comme notre
monde regorge d'une immense quantité de
particules et de rayonnement
le phénomène de décohérence est
extrêmement rapide voire pratiquement
instantanée par exemple un simple grain
de poussière dans l'atmosphère terrestre
en interagissant avec ses propres
particules ainsi qu'avec l'air ambiant
la lumière ou encore la chaleur va
perdre tout aspect quantique en à peine
un sextile ionienne de seconde
c'est à dire un milliardième de
milliardième de milliardième de
milliardième de seconde
c'est également à cause de la
décohérence que les phénomènes
quantiques ne peuvent être étudiées
qu'en laboratoire
en effet pour pouvoir examiner un objet
quantique
il faut éviter à tout prix la
décohérence car elle mettrait rapidement
fin aux propriétés quantiques que l'on
souhaite étudier
il est donc nécessaire d'isoler l'objet
un maximum pour éviter qu'ils
interagissent avec l'extérieur
il faut donc le placer dans un
environnement le plus vite possible avec
le moins de particules possible le moins
d'éclairage possible et le tout à une
température très proche du zéro absolu
ce n'est que dans ces conditions très
extrêmes créées artificiellement en
laboratoire que l'on arrive à ralentir
assez la décohérence pour avoir le temps
d'étudier des propriétés quantiques de
l'objet
[Musique]
le phénomène de décohérence quantique
est donc omniprésent dans notre
quotidien
il explique pourquoi à notre échelle le
monde se comporte de façon classique 100
phénomènes quantiques
comme tous les objets de notre quotidien
baigneaux constamment dans un
environnement rempli d'atomes de lumière
et de chaleur
ils vont interagir avec tous ces
éléments extérieurs est ainsi très
rapidement perdre leurs propriétés
quantiques
[Musique]